through okay
great
yeah uh thank you so much for still
giving me the opportunity to talk even
though i couldn't make it in person
having some visa troubles which i'm sure
many of you were uh familiar with uh
struggling with those so
um hope you've all had a great uh
meeting
so uh this is gonna fit very
uh thematically well with the previous
talk because i'm gonna be talking quite
a bit about what we've been doing in
splicing although
um less thinking about connections to
chromatin
so
my lab like many labs in genetics is
interested in this question broadly of
how can variation at the dna level end
up contributing to human phenotypes like
genetic disease risk of course we think
this must happen through cellular
intermediates
that operate at the molecular level
one of the phenotypes that we're very
interested in is rna splicing
and i don't need to introduce that since
you've got that loaded into working
memory from the previous talk
and so
alternative splicing can result in
differences in
trait
outcomes
and i'm going to talk about two projects
that sort of span this figure so one is
going to be trying to understand genetic
effects on splice factor binding i'm not
going to have time in 30 minutes to talk
about what we've been doing on an
approach to looking at splicing
variation transcriptome wide and sort of
splicing modules approach but i will
tell you about work we're doing on
causal network inference to try and
connect these sort of intermediate
phenotypes to
organize more level phenotypes
so the kind of starting point for this
work was that one of the projects i
worked on during my postdoc was
this
splicing quantification algorithm called
leafcutter
which does short read analysis from rna
sequencing data and gives a very
flexible and scalable approach so the
basic idea is illustrated here so if you
have some little genomic region where
black blocks here are corresponding to
the constitutive exons of a gene and
white blocks to alternative exons or
excellent extensions
the spliced reeds you might see
in the region might look something like
this
and what leaf cutter does is to
construct this intron graph where nodes
correspond to
starts and ends and splice junctions
detected in the rna sequencing data
and the
uh the the core thing that leafcutter
does is to look for these connected
components i think probably all of you
for this audience know what a connected
component is
and then the quantification we use is to
ask how many spliced reads mapped to
each splice junction relative to the
other splice junction in the same
connected component
we have some statistical machinery based
on a dirichlet multinomial generalized
linear model to test for splicing
differences between different conditions
or different genotypes
so we and others have used leaf cutter
to detect thousands of what are called
splicing qtls or associations between
common genetic variation and splicing
outcomes this is a figure from the most
recent gtex paper who used leafgutter
for their main splicing analysis
and we and others have also shown that
splicing qtls are often
just as enriched or even sometimes more
enriched than eqtls in gus this for
example is for multiple sclerosis it
depends which trait you look at which
way this goes but the big picture is you
don't want to ignore sqtls when you're
looking at the effect of non-coding
variation
but how are these variants actually
affecting splicing so i took this figure
from
again the most recent gtex paper
and here they looked at which regions in
the gene in the genome splicing qtls and
eqtls are enriched in and as you might
expect eqtls are enriched in promoters
and splicing qtls are enriched in
actually at the splice donor and the
splice acceptor and in known splice
regions
and for eqtls you do see this weak
enrichment in transcription factored
binding sites but noticeably missing
from this figure is anything about
splice factors or rbps more broadly
and we that's surprising because
you know our understanding of how
splicing is regulated is that it's
through a combination
of cis acting rna sequences in the
precursor messenger rna itself and then
transacting rna binding proteins splice
factors so
this is a complicated picture but there
are these exotic splicing enhancers it's
fine splicing silencers and equivalent
intronic
elements as well
and there's been surprisingly little
work trying to look at whether there are
snips that affect rbp binding and that
might therefore be affecting splicing
downstream there is a notable exception
which is this paper from grace gels
group
which looked at a large collection of uh
what's called e-clip uh profiling of
different rbps and two different cell
types so e-clip is sort of the chipseq
of um
rbp binding
and by counting uh heterozygote snips in
these two cell lines by counting the
number of reads coming from each allele
they could perform a statistical test
asking whether there seemed to be a
genetic effect on
rbp binding affinity and they were able
to find a decent number of these snips
that do seem to affect rbp binding but
of course they're pretty limited because
they can only look at heterozygote snips
in these two cell lines
so
we thought maybe
a way to go further than this would be
to pull multiple cell lines from
different individuals
and we were inspired to do this by work
from hunter phrases group at stanford
you've done a similar approach for
looking at transcription factor
binding effects using chip seek and
they've also had follow-up work using
attack seek and looking at dna
methylation as well
and there's a couple of reasons that
this works out very nicely so one is
that if you're interested in common
genetic variation you actually don't
need to pull very many individuals to
capture a
large proportion of common variants so
this is based on just genotype data from
gtex but
and we're going to end up using nine uh
pulling nine individuals and you can see
that you actually get almost 95 percent
of common snips represented even at this
relatively small
seeming sample size of course
partly we're being helped here by the
fact that we happen to be a diploid
species and also this is just
considering uh snips at least five
percent minor allele frequency so this
isn't going to work for rare variants
the other really nice
aspect of this is that we sort of
naturally control for the technical
variation that's the bane of large-scale
sequencing experiments
especially for functional genomics
because all of the experiments is being
done together
so
the way this is going to work is we're
pooling uh induced pluripotent stem
cells uh provided to us by kristen
brennan's lab at yale
and then we do
rna immunoprecipitation and sequencing
or rip seek um this is a sort of
competitor method to eclipse we're doing
this mainly because my postdoc meghan
scherzer who uh is driving this project
had generated beautiful rip c data
during her phd
and so there's a protocol we were very
comfortable with we also think it
actually has some advantages as well in
terms of specificity so
we if you focus on the cyan tracks here
these two are our data and this bottom
row is from uh encode we see rough
agreement in where peaks are our peaks
are broader which in this setting can
actually be good for capturing more
snips
and potentially more specific so you see
less non-specific binding outside of
clear peak regions
once we have our rip seek data from our
pool then we can try to
assess whether there's allele specific
binding
one fun thing you can do with this sort
of experiment is from the sequencing
data itself you can get an estimate of
how much each individual is represented
in the actual pool and we aim for that
to be even across the different
individuals but it's impossible to
guarantee that in practice
so the way this works is
to fit the simple linear regression
where y here is going to be the allelic
ratio maybe i should call this a
proportion for snip i
and then
the x's here are going to be the dosage
for individual eye and sorry individual
j and snip i
coded as 0 for homozygous reference 0.5
for a heterozygote and one for the
homozygote
alternate
and
these betas once we fit this model will
end up corresponding to the proportion
that individual j contributed to the
pool
when we run this on the two biological
replicates we have we see very good
consistency regardless of which um
sequencing output we look at so here
there are three different
you know precipitations that we did so
for hrp a k h9pa1 and rbsox2 and
importantly also you do it we you would
you always do an input to control for
expression variation so this is
effectively just a total rna sequencing
run
i'm not going to talk about the igg this
is to control for non-specific binding
we have sort of a
internal control by accident here and
that this cell line actually wasn't
included in this biological replica
and so it should be at zero so this
gives you some sense of what the
estimation error is here um of course
you can really have negative proportions
of a cell line so we uh we have an
improved version now where we can strain
those faders to be positive and so that
that effect
goes away
so
the main challenge in analyzing this
data is that we want to distinguish
allele specific expression effects from
allele-specific binding of the rbp
the way we do this is in a bayesian
probabilistic model which i'll try to
briefly describe
so
from those estimated proportions those
betas and the genotype data that we have
for the lines we have what we think is a
pretty accurate estimate of the allelic
ratio
of the
for the two alleles for each net at the
dna level
and then we model the unobserved true
allelic ratio in the rna input
as being beta distributed with mean
equal to the elite ratio and the dna and
then some concentration parameter which
controls how different they're going to
be globally and this is to model allele
specific expressions so is one allele
transcribed more than the other well it
could be effect on decay rate as well
the data that we have that's informative
about this olivic ratio are the allelic
counts in the rna input we model those
as being beta binomial distributed with
mean equal to this r
and a dispersion parameter d
then this is sort of the interesting bit
from the statistical statistical point
of view and the biology is whether there
are allele specific binding effects so
that would correspond to the true
allelic ratio in the ip'd data being
different
to the alien ratio in the input and
again we use the beta distribution here
with a mean equal to
the allele ratio of the rna level
um and another concentration parameter
that's going to be learned from the data
and then we uh the data that we have
that's informative about the allele
ratio in the ip are the allelic counts
for the ip and again we use a beta
binomial distribution here with another
dispersion counter
so
reasonably complicated probabilistic
model
but we were able to fit this very
efficiently
using pyro which is a probabilistic
programming language which sits on top
of pi torch and gives you all the
advantages that deep learning gets of
you know gpu-based computation and so on
we then have a statistical test uh based
on a z-score
and
for h9pk which is the rbp where we've
done the most the deepest sequencing
we estimate that over seven thousand
snips show allele specific binding
effects and that's about two percent of
testable snips
um for comparison the hunter phrases
hunter phrases were transcription
factors in a similar way
was also estimating between one and two
percent of testable snips having effects
on transcription factor binding um
depending on which specific
transcription factor you're looking at
this is the uh 10 fdl
of course what we're really interested
in doing with this is asking
whether these snips that affect rbp
binding seem to have downstream effect
on splicing and the way we're doing that
is through a statistical genetics
approach so we're taking
leafcutter splicing qtls from ipscs from
this nice meta-analysis
doing statistical fine mapping so this
gives you per variant posterior
inclusion probabilities so probability
that a specific snip is the actual
causal snip for a splicing change
and then we use a simple weighted
logistic regression which i can talk
about more people are interested
to estimate enrichment of these
different features so we have a couple
of control features whether the snip is
genic whether it's exotic whether it
falls in a binding peak for hrmpk
and then finally whether it's called as
a allele specific binding qtl
and all of these
get positive and significant
coefficients this is a regression model
so these effects are additive so a snip
that is in a binding peak
has is more likely to affect splicing
than otherwise but if it's also called
as a asb qtl then it has a considerably
greater chance of influencing splicing
so we're very pleased to see that um and
we're following up on this looking at
other um splice factors and um also
using more individuals as well
so the second vignette i want to talk
about is around causal network inference
so probably many of you are aware of
mendelian randomization since it's being
quite widely used in human genetics now
and the basic idea is to use snips as
what are called instrumental variables
to deal with this issue that if you're
trying to ask whether a specific
exposure x causally affects an outcome y
you're always worried about confounders
u so in mr
if you're willing to make the assumption
that your snips
do not
affect the confounder and only affect
the outcomes
via the exposure
then you can get an estimate of this uh
beta the causal effect of x on y
and you can even relax this assumption a
little bit that there's no other parts
from the snip to the outcome when you
have in the situation where you have
multiple snips and so the most widely
used approach is called ego regression
basically you plot
on the x-axis the association between
the instrument and the exposure the
y-axis the association between the
instrument and the outcome and the slope
of this ends up being a robust estimate
from theta
but in reality we don't normally just
have two traits that we're interested in
exposure and outcome in reality
phenotypes and traits live in complex
directed networks where there are
biomarkers and diseases machine
expression and also unmeasured
confounders so how do we think about
trying to do
media randomization in this in this more
sort of realistic setting
so we came up with
a relatively simple linear model which
we think captures a lot of what you'd
want to capture in these networks so
here
this is phenotype j
is given by
effects from other phenotypes through
this graph g
and then by genetic effects so x here
would be genotype and
beta being regression coefficients
finally gamma would represent unmeasured
confounding
and we can change this into matrix
notation shown here
and what we're really interested in
doing is asking whether we can separate
out direct effects of one trait on
another versus mediated effects through
that network
and in the case where you have
the this r matrix the total effect
matrix so this is
the true underlying effect of a on b for
every pair of traits a and b including
direct effects that are mediated through
the network
and then under the model i just showed
you it turns out you can
calculate exactly analytically g this
matrix of direct effects using this
expression
where here d is just a
term things worried about t measures is
a normalization factor the interesting
part really here is this inverse this
matrix inverse so if you've seen um
gaussian graphical models the graphical
lasso before this might look a little
familiar this is very analogous to
converting um correlations to partial
correlations where you're conditioning
on other
variables in your
network there are two problems with this
though the first is
even in the best case scenario not all
traits are going to be observed so we
need to worry about uh what that's
called correlated player trophy so those
are
confounders that have themselves have a
genetic component
and we i'm not going to go into it in
any detail but we recently published a
paper with a very straightforward
extension to egg regression that copes
with this there are also some elegant um
mixture model based approaches to
solving this problem um that are more
computationally intensive but work
better in some scenarios although also
worse than others
the second problem is we don't know
we can't even
we don't know the exact total causal
effect matrix we just have an estimate
of it r hat and unfortunately this is
not one of these situations where you
can just plug in an estimator and have
everything work out nicely and the
reason for that is this matrix inverse
is not very stable so you can imagine
this can if there's a lot of noise
contributing to small eigenvalues or
singular values in here then those are
going to get amplified by the matrix
inverse
the solution we came up with was to use
this convex optimization formulation of
this problem
so
here r is our total effect matrix or
estimate of it for mendelian
randomization
v is going to be an approximate matrix
inverse of r
and
that is
specified via this loss and then we have
this regularization which so this is a
lasso or graphical lasso like
regularization and it puts an l1 penalty
l1 penalty on every element of d
and we set this up in this slightly
convoluted way so by
constraining that matrix u times matrix
v has to be equal to the identity
because it lets us use this optimization
approach called alternating direction
method and multipliers which is a very
elegant approach for solving these sort
of biconvex optimization problems
we have these weights w which let us
account for standard errors coming from
the mr
we have a stability criterion adapted
from a similar approach to graphical
lasso for lambda
and the connection is graphical lasso
which gives you undirected networks so
there's a lot of why we're sort of um
you think this approach makes a lot of
sense
we've done a large number of i should
say brelin really has done a large
number of uh simulations generating
random graphs with different um
characteristics and also different ways
of orienting the edges
and we seem to be broadly robust to
the sort of network how the network
looks and
it's an interesting problem because
there aren't
very obvious baselines to compare to you
but the sort of simple baselines we can
come up with we perform much better than
the big uh sort of real world
application we've done with this is to
look at the uk biobank so we end up
looking at
just over 400 traits based on various
filters
out of those
around five percent have significant
total causal effects on each other
and those
8 000 or so total causal effects are
explained by a direct effect network
that we estimate that has just under 3
000 edges
and then we can start to look at
interesting properties of that directed
network so we can see that most nodes
have no causal effects
but there are
hub nodes that have a very large number
of downstream effects for example bmi
we also see very high connectivity so
any node
which influences or that affects at
least one other node can affect any node
in the network eventually
by propagating effects through the
network
we also see very pervasive mediation
so if you take a pair of nodes a pair of
traits that have a significant total
causal type between them the median path
length is actually two so that says it's
more common that when you see an effect
of a on b it's through an effect on c
rather than being direct and also the
shortest path between two nodes
on average only explains 52 percent of
bearing so there's if affects b there's
often two parts through the network in
which through which affects be
the direction we're going with this
project is to try to think about using
it to estimate the
directed
gene regulatory networks underlying
complex traits and to do this we need
large-scale trans eqtl and sqtl
mapping
to do that in collaboration with toffee
raj is lab at mount sinai we've been
collating and uniformly processing all
the
publicly available
post-mortem brain rna sequencing data we
can get our hands on
calling transient qtls and we think that
the sort of the sort of sample sizes
we're getting to around five or six
thousand individuals
we should start to see a significant
number of transient ttls and that does
seem to be to be playing out
this connects to work from my old lab at
stanford uh around the omnigenic
proposed homogenic model that says that
maybe one of the reasons many traits
look so polygenic is that gene
regulatory networks are so densely
connected that you can perturb almost
any gene in the network and that effect
will eventually propagate on to the
trait you're looking at
so
um acknowledgements here should mostly
go to megan and breeland he did the bulk
of this work um and i'm very happy to
take questions
thank you david it was all so clear
thank you very much for trying out
no problem
glad it's a good it's a one plus of the
pandemic is that uh
this stuff runs a lot more smoothly
these days because we're all used to
doing it